welcome to this video playing the
Templar assassin should have played
shamel arslaan off I don't remember
playing him at all okay I went a farm
poor change some tirage I've got zero
order to answer guy was that a good idea
to go against exactly to go against him
with 1.e4 I don't know you three that's
a line that I always liked and recommend
it to people cutting out any Bishop
before moves and preparing before
gaining lots of space all right takes on
be fine f eight eggs hmm ok so this
looks nice doesn't it that just good
space advantage maybe you can use the
weakened see foursquare that's certainly
true
any trickery he wants to go Knight b6
quickly I guess ah interesting that's
really interesting okay Drago 92 or
night age 39 h 3 might be an idea I want
to be quick in this game so I'm night c4
yeah nights it formed I wonder maybe I
can take and play play for quick
development here my it doesn't look like
it should work
hmm i don't think i can take hmm i just
got a 5 coming that seems seems like
black it's okay here at least okay maybe
more
maybe he can't really go away five no f5
Teague's night f4 is this making any
sense I can also play Bishop f2 maybe
let's do that not so much I don't want
to keep the bishop so I want to play
Bishop age for it could be could be
something ok so he wants to take their
out it's difficult to prevent any way
okay visual aid for you can take take
one to four okay so let's take this
going to lose some pole on the queenside
anyway it's very little that I can do
about it some f5 maybe takes Knight F
form should be six I don't really see
any great tactical idea probably because
there isn't any answer it's quite often
the problem just say I don't see
anything great and sometimes the reason
is there isn't anything yeah well
something like G for my linden h5 is
possible I guess
yeah I don't know it's probably lost
anyway or worse at least might as well
try to irritate black quite sure what I
did wrong there that a six Quincy 7b 596
that look good did I check a check to
check the name right someone I don't
know Shambala Sloan off really no idea
what that is yeah at least that G for
more seems to yeah make him thinking so
here we go
so is f6 the move yeah thank you i'm
going sure i have to do something
drastic so here we go if I gold Bishop
g3 now he will go boom twinbee 695 okay
let's let's get out of the diagonal down
he really just wants to drive this pawn
home
okay my idea now is to take on f7 and
play g5 I don't know that it looks
somewhat dangerous
one minute 11 huh that's not good now
also taking age seven not sure this
isn't this isn't really is so clear in a
practical game even though we probably
have something that will will defend
yeah come on fire each takes Knight eggs
check Bishop takes Bishop d3 chickens my
quick quickly calculated idea one issue
is more as always the maid down on age
to check yeah anyway that's a chick you
will move the King I cannot play Bishop
d3 this is really awful
not being able to play this move is is
really awful shoot I don't want to lose
this game i really don't i felt that i
couldn't try something but didn't do a
go at all hmm well play them now does it
work nope rezai just bad game really
wonder wasn't wasn't this kind of
dangerous compounds to go night f4 here
this is clearly dangerous but maybe this
is the wrong approach I don't know six
here in 26 ride f7 and wins okay so what
exactly did I miss I have to go Bishop
g3 first and then I'm winning yeah I
couldn't really believe it that this is
amended it must be dangerous here they
have file and he's got all this stuff
sitting here now and it's flat-out
winning really winning directly plus 4
no nado that's easy now it's really easy
now it did fault sir just falls apart
with with simple moves I shoot just a 25
a bit too I took quickly and then then I
really already don't have anything check
here I'm just plain lost with the made
on age too it's a shame yeah because I
really felt that he didn't play that
right he made no defensive
ever yeah just push this before and so
on and I felt I mean some kind of
Defense move should be in order i mean
i've been taking with all pieces here
also had bishop g3 this is probably also
good right I that also wins ah come on
what a shame and what a shame zero out
of three against this guy is that a good
score nope thing okay maybe next time
thanks for watching